[موسيقى]
على مدارس سنوات مضت ظلت الامم المتحده
ومنظمات دوليه اخرى تحذر من مخاطر التغير
المناخي ورغم المؤتمرات العديده التي عقدت
منذ قمه الارض فينيرو عام 92 من القرن
الماضي مرورا باتفاقيتي كيوتو وباريس الى
توصيات مؤتمر شرم الشيخ العام الماضي فان
المخاطر ما فتئت تزيد والاوضاع تسوء اكثر
فاكثر في قلبي هذه التغيرات وتداعياتها
منطقتنا العربيه فقد شهدت بعض دولها موجات
حر وجفاف شديدين وبعضها الاخر عانى من
عواصف رمليه وحرائق وفيضانات خلفت اضرارا
على مستوى البنيه التحتيه وخسائر في
الارواح والممتلكه فلماذا فشلت قمم المناخ
العديده في الحد من الاثار الكارثيه
لظاهره التغيرات المناخيه وكيف ستتعامل
الدول العربيه مع الاخطار المحدثه
المتزايده التي تهدد امنها المائي
والغذائي اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم منذ سنوات والعالم يعاني من
تداعيات التغيرات المناخيه وفي ظل توقعات
بتفاقم ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري وتسارع
وتيرتها تزداد المخاوف من الانعكاسات
الكارثيه للتغير المناخي التي طالت العديد
من البلدان ومن بينها بلدان عربيه عن هذه
الانعكاسات والتحذيرات المتكرره من
تاثيراتها على الاوضاع الانسانيه
والغذائيه خاصه في منطقتنا العربيه يسعدنا
ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور زين العابدين الحسيني
استاذ التشريع البيئي والتنميه المستدامه
بالمغرب من بغداد الدكتور نظير عبود فزع
الخبير في التغيرات المناخيه ومن باريس
الدكتور بدوي رهبان الخبير في التغير
المناخي والكوارث الطبيعيه ومدير الحد من
الكوارث الطبيعيه في اليونسكو سابقا فاهلا
بهم جميعا
يستعد العالم لموسم صيفي شديد الحراره بعد
سبعه عوامل من مرور ظاهره النينيو
المناخيه عام 2016 والتي جعلته اكثر
الاعواب حرا على الاطلاق لكن يبدو ان احدى
السنوات الخمس المقبله ستكون على الارجح
الاكثر حراره على الاطلاق حسب تقديرات
المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
حذرت المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه من
ارتفاع غير مسبوق في درجات الحراره خلال
السنوات الخمس المقبله وقالت ان الفتره
الممتده بين 2023
والفين وسبعه وعشرين ستصبح بشكل شبه مؤكد
اكثر حراره على الاطلاق على كوكب الارض
ورجحت المنظمه ان تتجاوز درجات الحراره
عتبه درجه مئويه ونصف المسجله ما قبل
الثوره الصناعيه بشكل مؤقت وبتواتر اكبر
وتوقعت المنظمه ان تشهد الفتره المقبله
تطور ظاهره النينيو والمناخيه التي تتزامن
بشكل عام مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده
في الجفاف في بعض انحاء العالم وامطار
غزيره في مناطق اخرى
وقدرت المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
عدد الكوارث جراء الظواهر المتطرفه
المرتبطه بالطقس والمناخ بنحو 12 الف
كارثه خلال السنوات الخمسين الماضيه
مشيره الى ان هذه الكوارث اودت بحياه اكثر
من مليوني شخص واسفرت عن خسائر اقتصاديه
بقيمه
4.3 تريليون دولار وكانت البلدان الناميه
خاصه في اسيا وافريقيا هي الاكثر تضررا هل
تشاهدت تسعا من كل عشر وفيات وتكبدت 60%
من الخسائر الاقتصاديه
البلدان والمجتمعات الاكثر ضعفا التي لم
تفعل شيئا يذكر للتسبب في ازمه المناخ كما
قال
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور زين العابدين الحسيني
مرحبا
الارقام مفزعه الحقيقه جدا جدا بالنسبه
لهذه الخمس سنوات المقبله والتي
تقول المنظمه العالميه للرصاد الجويه
بانها ستكون الاكثر حراره على الاطلاق هل
من تفسير
هو اولا يجب التذكير على انه سنه 22 كانت
سجلت ارقاما قياسيه غير مسبوقه في سجلات
الارصاد الجويه عبر العالم وخصوصا في جنوب
اوروبا وكذلك في دول المغرب الكبير هذه
حقيقه حقيقه جاءت لتتوج خمس سنوات كلها
عجاف وخمس سنوات من الجفاف وعدم انتظام
التساقطات ولذلك ليس مستبعدا ولا مستغربا
ان تكون السنوات حتى سنه 2030 تسير على
نفس الوتيره لانه دائما نفس الاسباب تولد
نفس النتائج
فالانبعاثات لا زالت في المستويات
صعبه جدا ومرتفعه
بالرغم من كل ما اتخذ منذ مؤتمر باريس
كوبو 21 الى الان
يعني ظاهره النينيو عندما عندما حدثت
افرزت مجموعه من الظواهر هي حدثت في
المحيط الهادي ولكنها اثرت كثيرا لو
نوضحها اكثر هذه الظاهره هذه ظاهره
النينيو كانت تحدث في ديسمبر يعني في
نهايه كل سنه
وتحدث على السواحل البيروفيويا يعني في
جمهوريه البيرو وكان البحارون يسمونها
الطفل يعني
نسبه الى طفل يسوع باللغه الاسبانيه
باللغه الاسبانيه وبحسب التقاليد التي
كانت سائده في هذا المناطق هذه الظاهره
تتجلى في انه مياه البحر السطحيه كانت
ترتفع درجه حرارتها بشكل لا يتناسب مع
الوقت ومع الفتره الزمنيه
فهذا الارتفاع في درجه الحراره كان ينتج
ظواهر مناخيه
على نوعين في السواحل الشرقيه مثلا كانت
هناك امطار طوفانيه
تتطور لكي تصبح عصير او اعصارات يعني
اعصار يتلوه اعصار وهذه الظواهر كانت تحدث
في المحيط الهندي الاستوائي بالخصوص هذه
الظاهره كان من نتائجها هو انه ما يعتبر
يعني مناطق الضغط او المرتفعات الجويه
التي تحدث في المحيطات وتؤثر على اتجاه
السحب صارت تتركز وتغير امكينتها كما يحدث
مثلا بالنسبه للمرتفع الاثوري في المغرب
الذي يتموقع ويبقى في منطقه معينه لمده
طويله كل يعني
التساقطات وكل السحب الممطره اللي من
المفروض انها تصل الى المغرب تغير طريقه
وهذه الظواهر تتكرر في مناطق كثيره من
العالم مما ينتج انعدام التساقطات وما
يعرف بالظواهر القصوى الظواهر القصوى هو
انه نبقى شهر بدون امطار وعندما تاتي
الامطار تاتي في روسيا يوم واحد مما يسبب
فيضانات ويسبب الكوارث هذه الاشياء مع
الاسف هي مرشحه للاستمرار وللزياده اللهم
اذا كانت يعني الايرادات وكذلك القرارات
اصحاب القرار يجب ان يتخذوا ما ينبغي
اتخاذه واوله هو ان يؤمنوا بما يقوله
الخبراء لانه اليوم العالم يتوفر على
تقارير في غايه الجوده مثلا مجموعه
الخبراء المناخ التي يرمز اليها بالجيك هي
تنتج سنويا يعني تقارير عاليه الدقه لابد
من الفاعل السياسي وهنا افتح قوسا لاقول
على انه الان موضوع التغيرات المناخيه يجب
لك ان يكون الاول في جميع المؤتمرات في
جميع الاجتماعات الحكوميه لانه الان
التنميه والعلاقات الدوليه ووضعيه السكان
وقضيه المجاعه كلها مرتبطه بهذا الامر ليس
طرفا على الاطلاق ليس طرف على الاطلاق كما
كانت من ضمن التوقعات ايضا الدكتور نظ
نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته وشكرا للاستاذ زين العابدين
على هذه المقدمه وشرح الوافي الحقيقه
التفسير بانه الان نحن تحدثنا عن ظاهره
نينو ولكن موضوع الكلايم تشينج يسمى
بالانثروبات وهو تغير المناخ الناتج عن
تاثيرات الانسان فلذلك الغازات المنبعثه
هي يعني زادت الطين بله واصبح هناك تسارع
كبير في موضوع التغيرات المناخيه اما في
خصوص اسيا وافريقيا نعم لكون هذه المناطق
فيها اغلب المناطق تعد مناطق هشه والحقيقه
في موضوع التغيرات المناخيه هناك تصنيفات
في انه احنا نصنف المناطق على انه هي هشه
ولكن يترابط مع هذا المصطلح مصطلح اخر
يسمى
بالدقابليه التكيف وعلى هذا الاساس هناك
تقارير ممكن انه نتحدث عنها في مقاطع اخرى
من اللقاء تقارير تخص المنطقه العربيه
وتصنف المناطق على ان المناطق هشه او
مناطق معرضه
اكسبوستنج وايضا تعرف ان اذا كانت هي
قابليه تكيفها عاليه من هذه كلها تعطى
درجات الدرجات قد تكون له او قد تكون
متوسطه او قد تكون عاليه فمناطق افريقيا
واسيا الحقيقه نتيجه يعني الوضع والفقر
اللي موجود في هذا الموضوع سكانهم والناس
ثم قابليه تكيفهم ضعيفه لذلك اثار
التغيرات المناخيه يتوقع ان يكون عليها
اثر كبير على هذه المناطق
وهناك قائمه الحقيقه بالدول التي تسمى
بالمناطق الاكثر هشاشه وعدد كبير منها في
هذه القائمه هي من افريقيا نعم الدكتور
فزع مثل ما اشار الدكتور الحسيني هنا في
الاستوديو مساله وجود فجوه بين الخبراء
ومراكز الدراسات في هذا المجال والفاعلين
السياسيين هل هل تتوقع ان تستمر هذه
الفجوه لانها اصبحت الان كارثيه الحقيقه
نعم هذا حقيقه يعني جدل قديم وحديث ومستمر
لان الخبراء دائما هم يحددون المشكله لكن
من الصعب جدا ان تصل لما يسمى
ولاصحاب القرار حتى تعمل التنفيذ في هذا
الموضوع وانطيك مثال على هذا الموضوع يعني
الموضوع التغير المناخي ابتدا بالتركيز من
1828 الى سنه
1988 اصبحت هناك مايلستون سنه مهمه لان في
الكونجرس الامريكي احد
الباحثين والعلماء وقف امام الكونجرس
الامريكي وبين لهم بانه
يعني فلذلك الحقيقه من ذلك الوقت تغير
موضوع التغير المناخي والنظره الى وتاسست
ما تسمى
اصبحت هناك اتفاقيه
اصدرت تقريرها الاول 1990 واصبحت هناك
اتفاقيات ريو في 1992 اللي هي خاصه
والتنوع البيولوجي والتصحر من اجل انه
تتقل هذه المشاكل الكبيره لتخفف منها
ولتنظر الها في هذا المجال فنعم نعم
الموضوع والدلمه هذه والارض بان اصحاب
القرار والباحثين هي مستمره ويحتاج انهم
يصغوا الى النتائج والى التقارير العلميه
المهمه الدكتور بدوي رهبان وانت تحدثنا من
باريس عندما انعقدت قمه باريس كانت الامال
واسعه وعريضه على ان العالم قد يكون ادرك
اخيرا ان عليه ان يتحرك بقوه ونجاعه
لاحتواء الانعكاسات السلبيه للاحتباس
الحراري ومعالجه التداعيات لماذا فشل
برايك
اولا ان اتفاق باريس لم يفشل ان اتفاقيه
باريس للمناخ كانت حقبه اساسيه
ومحطه مهمه في مسار نقاش مشكله تغير
المناخ ومواجهه تبعات تغير المناخ
عندما تم المؤتمر هنا في باريس عام 2015
على مستوى قاده الدول وايضا على مستوى
المشاركين من القطاع الخاص من المجتمع
المدني من البلديات من الافراد لم يكن
متوقعا ان يخلص اتفاق باريس بالاتفاقيه
التي نتجت عنه
لذلك هو محطه تاريخيه في مسار مواجهه تغير
المناخ هذا المسار الذي لم يبتدئ في عام
2015 ان مسار مواجهه تغير المناخ ابتدا
بعام
1988 89 عندما شكل الهيئه الحكوميه
المعنيه بالمناخ في الامم المتحده التي
تعرف بالانجليزيه
وتعرب بالفرنسيه بجيك وتعرف بالعربيه
بهيئه الحكوميه لتغير المناخ ان هيا
الحكوميه للتغير المناخ
انشات في العام
1989 لم تنشا امس او لم تنشا في باريس اذا
ان مسار مواجهه تغير المناخ حقق تقدما حقق
تقدما في العشرين سنه الماضيه ولكن كانت
هناك مطبات ومن ضمنها مطبات للاسف في في
تنفيذ اتفاقيات باريس اتفاقيه باريس لم
تنفذ كما هي او كانت تنفيذها جزئيا بعده
اسباب اولا لان الاراده السياسيه التي
كررت هنا في باريس عن 2015 لم تنفذ لم
ينفذ قاده الدول تعهداتهم من جهه ثانيا
اتت جائحه الكورونا اتت جائحه الكورونا
لتصطدم بمسار تنفيذ تغير المناخ في
اتفاقيات باريس رابعا ان المشكلات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ايضا في العامين
الماضيين ومن ضمنها الحرب في اوكرانيا
خلقت صعوبات ايضا
صعوبات جديده
تنفيذ اتفاقيات باريس اذا اذا ان مسار هو
ما زال قائما ولكن يشهد مطبات يشهد نكسات
من ضمنها ايضا طبعا نكست انسحاب امريكا في
العام 2018 من اتفاقيه باريس هذه انكسات
يجب ان لا نواجهها في المستقبل ويجب ان
نعي ذلك وان نعي ان نعي ان التعويل فقط
على الحكومات والاراده السياسيه لا يكفي
مواجهه تغير المناخ تتطلب تغييرا عميقا في
سلوك كل فرد منا تغييرا عميقا في نماذج
حياتنا اليوميه تغييرا عميقا في دور
فعاليات المجتمع المدني القطاع الخاص
ربما المشكل ان تقريبا لا منطقه دكتور
حسين
بمنعه عن هذه المساله لو لو نحاول الان ان
نخصص اكثر وندخل في تفاصيل بعض المناطق
يعني مثلا حوض المتوسط
الدراسات تقول بان الحراره القصوى في
منطقه المتوسط
ستزداد او تزداد الان بوتيره اسرع من اي
منطقه اخرى
وبالتالي فالمغرب او الجزائر او تونس او
ليبيا او موريتانيا او عرضه لمثل هذه
الظواهر
ما ابرز ما ستعانيه هذه المنطقه جراء ذلك
اول شيء يجب ان لا نستثني جنوب اوروبا
لانه دول الحوض الشمالي للمتوسط يعني
الدول الاوروبيه هي بدورها تاثرت وتتاثر
وسيصيبها ما اصاب الاخرين
فقط للتدليل على ذلك نقول على انه مثلا
دوله مثل فرنسا منطقه الالزاس واللورين
التي هي هي منطقه معروفه بثلوجها
وبامطارها هي الان تعاني من انكماش في
الفرشاه المائيه وفي مصادر الجوفيه للماء
اسبانيا 74% من اراضيها مهدده بالتصحر
بسبب نقص المياه السطحيه وعليه
منذ مده والامر لم يبدا البارحه
فالمتوسط وخصوصا وخصوصا غرب المتوسط يعاني
من هذه الظاهره اكثر من الكثير من الاماكن
في العالم ولكن اعود مره اخرى لاقول على
انه هذه مساله منذ 2012 لانه
اذا كان هذا المشكل اصبح دوليا ومؤرقا منذ
مؤتمر الذي سمي مؤتمر الارض
وهذه القضيه ظهرت في سنه 2012
بالضبط في الدوره الثامنه عشره لمؤتمر
الكوب الذي عقد هنا في الدوحه
ومن هنالك انا اعتقد انه قد بدا العد
العكسي لهذه الظواهر بدات التساقطات يعني
في عدم الانتظام بدا يعني مخزون او رصيد
كل دوله
من الماء في التناقص
والاسباب كثيره اذكر من بينها يعني على
سبيل المثال انه الحراره المفرطه التي
شهدت هذه المناطق ادت الى ارتفاع نسبه
التبخر من جهه ثم انه العادات الاستهلاكيه
للمواطن في هذه المناطق
جعلت الطلب على الماء يزداد لانه هذه
الدول مثلا عندها قاسم مشترك وهو السياحه
والسياحه بدون ماء لا توجد سياحه بدون ماء
فالطلب على الماء من الصناعه السياحيه زاد
من الطنيبال لا
نظم الحرف ونظم الزراعه كانت منذ مده
تتطلب تطويرا تتطلب
عقلنتا وترشيدا
فالفلاحه 85% من المياه تذهب للفلاحه
وتذهب بشكل اعتباطي وعشوائي لو اعدنا
النظر في الطرق المعتمده لكنا قد ربحنا
الشيء الكثير منذ مده
فهذه الاسباب واخرى مختلفه تجعل التنميه
وهي اعز ما يطلب في هذه المناطق شيئا يصعب
يوما عن اخر وعندما تصعب التنميه يصعب
التشغيل تصعب تنميه اوضاع السكان الى غير
ذلك فهذا يجب ان يكون هما بالنسبه للح
بالنسبه للقرار السياسي وهو ما لا نحس به
الى حد الان هناك ايضا ظاهره دكتور ظاهره
الجفاف الذي اصاب البحيرات والمسطحات يعني
مثلا
سنستعرض ما اظهرته دراسه حديثه من ان اكثر
من نصف البحيرات والمسطحات المائيه
الكبيره في العالم تجف منذ اوائل
التسعينات القرن الماضي وجاء في الدراسه
التي نشرها فريق بحثي دولي بدوريه ساينس
العلميه الامريكيه ان 56% من انحسار مياه
البحيرات يعود الى الاحتباس الحراري
والنشاط البشري لكن تزايد درجات الحراره
له النصيب الاكبر في ذلك وتغطي البحيرات
حوالي 3% من سطح الارض لكنها تمثل 87% من
المياه العذبه وهي تستخدم للاستهلاك
البشري او الزراعه او حتى لانتاج الكهرباء
وقد اكدت دراسات اخرى اجريت في السنوات
القليله الماضيه ان حجم البحيرات ينكمش
على مستوى العالم ووفقا لبيانات جمعتها
هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه اعتمادا
على صور ملتقطه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه تبين
ان حجم بحيره سولتليك الكبرى مثلا والتي
تعتبر ثامن اكبر بحيره في العالم تقلص
بالفعل اذا تظهر الصوره الملتقطه في يونيو
حزيران عام 85 من القرن الماضي كيف كانت
مستويات المياه مرتفعه بينما تظهر الصوره
في يوليو تموز من عام 2022
انخفاضا قياسيا في مستويات مياه البحيره
هذه الظاهره دكتور الحسيني المغرب مثلا
يعاني منها
يعني بحيره
دايت عوا يعني ربما تقريبا جفت وكانت
منطقه سياحيه قبل قليل اشرت الى السياحه
كانت منطقه سياحيه معروفه ومشهوره الان
تقريبا يعني جافه تماما
هل هل هناك امكانيه للتدارك ان كانت هناك
امكانيه في الوقت الحاضر باستثناء الامطار
فليست هناك ايه امكانيه للتدارك اذا علمنا
ان المصادر الجوفيه للمياه بدورها تعاني
نحن وصلنا الى في الحفر في حفر الابار الى
اعماق ارقام قياسيه في الاعماق نتجاوز 600
متر من العمق للوصول الى الماء والماء
لنحضر اعمق واعمق واعمق واعمق وكل ما حفرت
اعمق فهناك مياه ذات جوده عاليه هو يعني
مخزون استراتيجي له مئات ربما الف السنين
والوصول اليه يؤثر كثيرا على التنوع
البيولوجي نحن من
يومين او ثلاثه العالم احتفل بيوم يعني
التنوع البيولوجي الذي
يصبح او يمسي كل يوم عزيزا نظرا لغياب
الماء
فاختفاء هذه البحيرات وهذه المياه السطحيه
يؤدي الى انه الحيوانات بمختلف اشكالها
وكل السلاسل التي كانت تعيش فيها او
بجوارها من طيور المهاجره الى الى غيرها
من الكائنات الاخرى بدورها تتاثر وعندما
يقع هذا الاختلال في التنوع البيولوجي
ينعكس ذلك اول ما ينعكس على صحه الانسان
بل اداه امر من ذلك فاذا تحدثنا عن
البحيرات او عن المياه السطحيه الطبيعيه
فحتى المياه السطحيه الاصطناعيه يعني
بحيرات السدود نظرا لان السدود تنقص بسرعه
كبيره وليست هناك امطار لتعويضها حتى هذه
البحيرات الاصطناعيه التي ارتبطت ايضا
بالسياحه وارتبطت بالصيد وارتبطت بكثير
اشياء اخرى هي بدورها تتناقص وينعكس على
المحيط بشكل يعني مقلق للغايه نعم اذا
كانت هذه الصور التي تابعناها من المغرب
العراق ايضا دكتور فزع ليس افضل حالا يعني
مثلا الاهوار الاهوار في في العراق تقلص
حجمها بنسبه 90%
والعراق يصنف كخامس دوله حسب التقارير على
الاقل خامس دوله في العالم متضرره ايام
تضرر من التغيرات المناخيه مثلا بالنسبه
للاهوار كيف حالها الان
شكرا على هذا السؤال الحقيقه يعني دعني
اولا انه اسلط الضوء على المنطقه العربيه
اغلب يعني المنطقه العربيه تقريبا 90% او
اكثر من مياهها تاتي من خارج المنطقه
العربيه لذلك هي تعد مناطق هشه لتغيرات
المناخيه اما في خصوص العراق يعني حضراتكم
تعلمون بانه احنا تقريبا 80 الى 85% من
مياهنا هي تاتي من تركيا وتقريبا 15 الى
20% تاتي من جانب ايران
المياه المتكونه داخل العراق هي قليله جدا
وفي ظل هناك اسباب حقيقه الان لدينا موضوع
شحه المياه يتصدر المشهد في العراق هي
المشكله الكبرى حاليا في العراق يعني الان
ولاول مره تاتينا ثلاث اربع سنوات جفاف
متتاليه يعني وهذا الحقيقه اثر بشكل كبير
على يعني على على المياه وعلى البحيرات
وعلى الاهوار بشكل عام حضرتك خصصت الاهوار
ولكن نمر في يعني مشكله كبيره على طول نهر
دجله وايضا نمر بمشكله كبيره ممكن اكبر
منها في نهر الفرات
هي تتكون من نهرين دجله والفرات ولذلك
نتيجه قله المياه في هذه الانهر اصبحت
الان متقلصه بشكل كبير اصبح هناك ثروه
الحيوانيه والجاموس اللي يعيش من فتره
السومريين الى الان 5000 سنه من الحضاره
اللي تعتمد على المياه بدات تجف وبدا
يتغير الديموغرافيا اللي موجوده بدات هناك
هجره للسكان من الاهوار ومن غير الاهوار
لدينا بحيرات كبيره نتيجه الجفاف وقله
المياه بدات الزراعه تعتمد على المياه
الجوفيه واثرت على هذه البحيرات بحيرات
عملاقه عندنا مثل الرزازه وغيرها بدات تجف
واصبحت اراضي فلذلك الحقيقه العراق يعني
يعد موضوع شحه المياه هو الاولويه الاولى
الناتجه من الكنترو يعني سيطره الدول
المنبع على والسياساتهم ولكن بنفس الوقت
موضوع التغير المناخي يعمل
درايفر كعامل اخر يؤثر على هذا الموضوع
وايضا يعني يعقد المشهد بالنسبه للعراق
رئيس الوزراء العراقي دكتور فزع ادعى الى
مؤتمر اقليمي في بغداد لدراسه التغيرات
المناخيه يعني هل هل تطمع في
مساعده دوليه او هبه دوليه لنجده العراق
في على الاقل في هذا المستوى
جفاف الاهوار في التسعينات يعني اثر على
مناطق الخليج عوده الاهوار من بعد 2003
بعد ما يعني فتحت السدود وعادت المياه الى
الاهوار هناك دراسات من مؤسسات كبيره في
الكويت ذكرت بانه المناخ تغير والطقس تغير
لديهم نتيجه عاش الاهوار في العراق
فالحقيقه الموضوع هو يعني ايضا مرتبط
الواحد بالاخر يعني المياه هي
تتعلق بالزراعه وتتعلق بمياه الشرب
وبالسكان ولكن من جانب اخر المياه مهمه
جدا للطبيعه ايضا وللتوازن الطبيعي فلذلك
سيد رئيس الوزراء المحترم يعني عمل في
البصره مؤتمر محلي كان بتداعيات ونقاشات
مع الامم المتحده الموجوده في العراق
ولكننا الان يعني نخطط الى مؤتمر اقليمي
هذا المؤتمر سيناقش كثير من الامور منها
عمليه التعاون ومنها عمليه التمويل ومنها
يعني عمليه تبادل المعلومات اللي هي
ضروريه جدا بين البلدان نعم اوروبا دكتور
رهبان ليست بمنعه عن هذه الظاهره طبعا
خاصه وان التقارير تشير الى ان درجات
الحراره في اوروبا
ترتفعت تقريبا بوتيره ضعف وترتفع ما ترتفع
في مناطق اخرى وهذا ادى الى استنفاذ
خزانات المياه واثر بشكل اتلف محاصيل
زراعيه حرائق في الغابات وغير ذلك
ما منتظر على الاقل في الصائفه المقبله
او هذه الصائفه بالاحرى
ان الدول الاوروبيه لم تاخذ خطوره تغير
المناخ
هذه الاهميه لتغير المناخ لقد ادركت
اهميتها خاصه في العامين الماضيين عندما
شهدت المانيا فيضانات هائله عندما شهدت
فرنسا موجات حر وجفاف وحرائق غابات وعندما
شهدت اسبانيا والبرتغال ايضا هذان العوامل
المناخيه المتطرفه اذا اوروبا دخلت الان
في زمن تغير المناخ والمواطنون ليس فقط
السياسيون ولكن المواطنون اصبحوا مدركين
لهذا الامر ومثلا هنا في فرنسا في شهر
مارس الماضي يعني من شهرين الحكومه
الفرنسيه
وضعت خطه خاصه بمواجهه الجفاف في صيف
القادم يعني بعد شهرين بعد شهر وضعت خصه
خطه مفصله في هذا الامر
خطه ايضا لمواجهه حرائق الغابات ودعت خطه
ايضا لشح المياه في الصيف اذا ان فرنسا لم
تعد تريد ان تفاجا في هذه الامور ارادت من
الان وصاعدا ان تكون استباكيه ان
تعي المواطنون ان تشجع المواطنون لكي يكون
عندهم ادراك لهذا الامر وهذا ما يحصل الان
هنا كذلك هي الحال في اسبانيا في البرتغال
وان مشكله المياه طبعا هي مشكله دوليه في
اسعار تغير المناخ وخاصه في الدول العربيه
كما ذكرنا ولكن ايضا في اوروبا ان مشكله
المياه هي المشكله الاولى من تبعات تغير
المناخ يعني على سبيل المثال على مستوى
الكون في العام 2030 يعني بعد سنه سبع
سنوات من اليوم في العام 2030 سوف يكون
هناك طلب للمياه على المستوى الك طلب
للمياه اربعين بالمئه زائد عما يمكن ان
يكون متاح للانسانيه اذا ان على مثلا
مدينه تقطن فيها الف ساكن الف ساكن او
1400 ساكن عفوا ربما فقط الف ساكن سوف الف
مواطن سوف يستطيعون ان
يستفيدوا من المياه وربما اربعه
مئه ساكن لن يتوفر لهم المياه هذه هي
الخطوره في هذا الامر هل هذا يقودنا حتما
دكتور الحسيني الى ضروره خطط على الاقل
لتقنين توزيع المياه وغيرها وهذا شاهدناه
حتى في بعض الدول تونس مثلا
ساعات معينه اكيد لبنان
مناطق اخرى اصبحت
تروم تقنين توزيع المياه في اوقات معينه
هل هذا على الاقل يخفف الاضرار في انتظار
ربما امطار او تغير الاوضاع مستقبلا هذا
يؤخر الوقوع في المحظور بالاساس لانه
عندما تلجا الى التوزيع فهذه مساله
ايجابيه في الاحتفاظ على ما هو متوفر
وموجود
يعني اطول مده ممكن نستعمل فيها هذا
الرصيد ولكن من ناحيه اخرى هو يفرز مجموعه
من الممارسات فالناس مثلا
المياه تاتي عاده عندما يكون هناك تقنين
في اوقات معينه من النهار وما تاتي في
منتصف الليل او تاتي بحسب التوزيع بحسب
شبكات التوزيع الى غير ذلك فقد نوجد في
حالات من التبذير ربما اكثر من الحالات
العاديه
حتى الوقت
تماما يعني وتقع تقع وتسجل يعني هذه مساله
عشناها يعني في السابق هذه القضيه ديال
تقنين التوزيع كان ينبغي ان تبدا منذ مده
على الاقل كتحسيس
وكان الناس يعني توعي يبص بقى بضروره من
باب التوعيه ونحن نقول للناس انتم
تتعاملون مع المياه وكانها لا تنضب ابدا
وكانها مصدر دائم والحاله ان هاته
الثروه هي معرضه للزوال وبالتالي كلما
استطعنا ان نرشد ونعقلنا استعمالنا فستطول
مياه البحر ليست حلا فعلا لانه
على الاقل في المغرب يعني حل ام ليست حل
لا هو حل حل لدرجه انه يمكن ان تعتبر او
يعتبر ان الخلاص فيما هو قادم ياتي من ما
يمكن تسميته بالمصادر غير التقليديه
اي تحريه ماء البحر ومن جهه اخرى معالجه
المياه العادمه واعاده استعمالها لان
هاتين التقنيه هي التي توجد الان متوفره
لدينا هذه تخفف الاضرار ليست حلا ليست حلا
جذريا جزء من الحل جزء اساسي من الحل
وطريقه للتخفيف لتخفيف من الاثار يعني
الجانبيه خصوصا على الصحه خصوصا حتى على
نفسيه السكان ولكنها ليست حلا لانه الحل
لا يكون الا بشيء اساسيين هو التوعيه
والتحسيس على اوسع نطاق ان ياخذ الجميع
هذه المساله على محمل الجد وعلى انها فعلا
مشكله كبيره لا يمكن ان يواجهها طرف من
المجتمع دون الطرف الاخر لابد وان يتجمع
الجميع وان يستفيدوا من الخبره التي تتوفر
سواء عن هيئات الامم المتحده سواء كما قلت
على هيئات البحث العلمي وان تاخذ ماخذ
الجد لانه هذه الطريقه الوحيده الان
متوفره ليست لنا طريقه اخرى هناك ظاهره
الدكتور يعني يعني
بودنه ان تفسرها لنا يعني هذه التغيرات
المناخيه ليست بالضروره سيئه للجميع يعني
مثلا هنا في منطقه الخليج الحراره تخف
امطار تنزل في غير مواسمها الثلج في
السعوديه درجات الحراره ليست بالقوه
المعتاده في شهر مثل شهر مايو او او يونيو
بينما مثلا في بعض المرات الحراره في بعض
دول المغرب الكبير اعلى من من الحراره في
قطر او في الكويت اذا ليست بالضروره كل كل
التداعيات سلبيه يعني هل يمكن ان نقول بان
منطقه الخليج تسير نحو مزيد من البروده
وحوض المتوسط واوروبا يصير نحو مزيد من
الحراره هل هذا الكلام صحيح ممكن وارد جدا
مثلا اعطيك مثال في المغرب المغرب المنطقه
الشماليه حيث توجد الغابات يعني منطقه
شمال الغربي هي رقم واحد في التساقطات في
المغرب
في الاربع سنوات الاخيره لم تعد كذلك
اصبحت تساقط تسقط في اكادير وفي سوسو وفي
الصحراء اكثر مما تسقط حتى انه مثلا وقعت
فيضانات في السماره وقعت فيضلت في افني
وهي مدن صحراويه فهذه هذه الظواهر القصوى
في الدول التي كان عندها معدل مثلا تصحر
معقول كان عند معدل تساقطات مرضي الى غير
ذلك
تطرح مشاكل كبرى اما تفضلت به من حيث انه
بعض الدول كدول الخليج مثلا فهذا يمكن ان
يصنف في اطار المقوله انه مصائب وقومي عند
قوم فوائد قد تكون ولكن هي في نهايه
المطاف
فطبيعه المنطقه طبيعه التساقطات طبيعه
الساكنه تتضرر ايضا لانه عندما تسقط مثلا
ثلوج وبرد وامطار في مناطق صحراويه مثلا
مثل الطائف في المكعب السعوديه او شيء من
هذا القبيل فهذا الامر هو غير طبيعي
تكون له تاثيرات جانبيه حتما ولا يستفيد
منها نظرا لانه ليست هناك بنيه استقبال
ليست هناك سدود ليست هناك تجهيزات يمكنها
ان تستفيد من هذا الماء فهو يسقط ويذهب في
الصحراء الدول المشكل على ذكر السدود
دكتور دكتور فزع بالنسبه
العراق مشكله المياه مع مع تركيا مشكله
قديمه ولكن على الاقل في المرحله المقبله
في انتظار سقوط الامطار اذا شاء الله
ما الذي ستسعى اليه العراق على الاقل
لتخفيف وطات ما يجري هناك لا نقول لايجاد
حل جذري ولكن على الاقل لتخفيف وطئه ما
يجري
نعم
استاذ محمد اسمحلي ايضا انه اتداخل في
السؤال السابق يعني الحقيقه في من المبكر
جدا انه نذكر بان منطقه الخليج تتجه
باتجاه افضل لان الحقيقه يجب ان تبنى
قراراتنا على التقارير العلميه وهناك ما
يسمى يعني بالاساس مثلا الان انا في يدي
واحد من التقارير اللي هي اساس للمنطقه
العربيه وفي هذه المنطقه تم اختيار اماكن
مهمه مثل النيل ودجله والفرات ومثل النهر
الكبير في في لبنان
وسوريا وايضا هناك نهر المجرده في تونس
وادي وادي الضيق في عمان فهذه كلها اصبحت
يعني هناك تقييم لها وتقييم يكون بناء على
درجات الحراره وتقييمها فلذلك هناك درجات
تعطى لهذه المناطق ومثل متوسطه قليله
مرتفعه
العراق الحقيقه ومنطقه الخليجيه لا زالوا
يحتفظون بالتصنيفات بانهما وسط الى عالي
الهشاشه فهنانا مهمه جدا لكن
موضوع القابليه التكيف هو هذا اللي يعطي
فروق بين البلدان ممكن نتحدث عنها في
اماكن اخرى في خصوص سؤال حضرتك حول السدود
والاجراءات العراقيه
مساله شحه المياه في العراق لدينا تعريفه
بانه هي من عده اسباب السبب الاول هو
السدود والاسباب الاخرى هو يعني اداره
المياه داخل العراق اللي يحتاج لها الى
تحسين والان هناك يعني تطور في هذا
الموضوع بقرارات من الحكومه بانه جميع
المزارعين لا يعطون قروض الا ان يستخدموا
طريقه الرش وطريقه
فهذه وايضا فتحه وموضوع يعني الضرائب على
هذه الاجهزه بالنسبه للفلاحين هناك
تسهيلات في موضوع الزراعه ايضا في خصوص
الامور الاخرى في موضوع استهلاك المياه
للشرب وللتوعيه وتعرف استاذ محمد من الصعب
جدا لحضاره بنيت من خمسه سبع الاف سنه على
المياه ومن نهرين عظيمين الان تتوجه الى
موضوع الجفاف فهذا الحقيقه يواجه المجتمع
العراقي صعوبه كبيره وايضا يواجه الحكومه
ايضا صعوبه في عمليه التكيف لهذا الموضوع
لكن انطيك اجراءات اخرى ايضا مثلا الاهوار
العراقيه نتيجه الجفاف هناك لدينا نهر
ثالث يسمى
هذا هو يعتمد في مصادره من مياه البزول من
المناطق الزراعيه فهو يذهب مباشره للخليج
في ابتداء من 2010 بدا العراقي يحور مسار
هذا النهر الثالث الى واستخدام هذه المياه
في الاهوار من اجل يعني الجفاف افضل هذا
الجواب على السؤال الجفاف افضل ام استخدام
هذه المياه افضل فالحقيقه مثلا في هول
الحمار تم استخدام هذه المياه كطريقه
للادابتيشن
هناك الان يعني توجه باتجاه التوعيه
وباتجاه المصانع ولدينا مشكله اخرى في
العراق وهي مساله استخراج النفط هناك
ملايين من المياه العذبه ايضا تستخدم في
استخراج النفط ففي ظل شحات المياه ايضا
نواجه يعني مشكله معقده في جميع القطاعات
وتحليه مياه البحر هي وحده من الحلول اللي
الان الحقيقه يتم نقاشها مع يعني احدى
الشركات الاجنبيه وان شاء الله يعني يكون
هناك تقنين لموضوع استخدامات المياه في
العراق دكتور روبان بالنسبه لاوروبا ما
الذي يمكن ان تقوم به خاصه وهي تشهد ايضا
انخفاض في مستوى الامطار لاول مره اصبحنا
نرى بعض الحدائق العامه سواء في لندن او
في عواصم اوروبيه اخرى وقد اصفرت وقد كانت
على الدوام تقريبا خضراء
نعم
سوف اجيب على سؤالك طبعا ولكن اريد ان
اشير الى ناحيه
الايسار الايجابيه او السلبيه لتغيير اريد
ان اشير الى ان الهيئه الحكوميه المعنيه
بالمناخ في الامم المتحده هيئه الخبراء لم
تلحظ في تقاريرها المتتاليه اي اثار تبعات
ايجابيه او مفيده لتغير المناخي اذا ان
خصوصيه تغير المناخ هي انه سوف يتسبب
بعوامل مناخيه متطرفه في في البلدان يعني
في بلد ما يمكن ان لم يشهد هذا البلد في
السابق فيضانات سوف يشهد فيضانات وان لم
يشهد في السابق موجات حر وجفاف سوف يشهد
موجات حر وجفاف قال بالعوده الى سؤالك عن
نسبه لاوروبا ان اوروبا بدات الان
بالاجراءات فرنسا كما اشرت عندها خطه الان
لمواجهه الجفاف عندها خطه للتقليل هناك
الاراضي فرنسيه فيما بعد البحار يعني في
الغوادالوب هناك اراضي بدات الان في جداول
زمنيه يقولون للمواطنين في هذا الاسبوع لن
تتمكنوا من الاستفاده باكثر من كذا بالمئه
من المياه العذبه اذا اصبح الان التقنين
وقحتمي في بعض المناطق في اوروبا كذلك
فيما خس الغابات ان المواطنين ان
المواطنين لا يستطيعوا ان يكون عندهم
احواض خاصه او ان يسبحوا في احواض خاصه في
في فصل الصيف القادم هنا في فرنسا
اذا كانت صوره بهذا الشكل الذي رايناه منذ
بدايه الحلقه دكتور الحسيني هل من الوارد
ارساء سياسه اقليميه يعني مثلا دول المغرب
الكبير منطقه المتوسط يعني هل هل امكانيه
اجتماع دول معينه على خطه تكامليه
وارد او ممكن له جدوى معينه بيئيا قد يكون
بالنسبه للدول التي يجمعها تجمعها احواض
مائيه
او تشترك في احواض مائيه مع دول اخرى ليس
واردا فحسب وانما ضروري
ولكن الدول التي لها مصادرها الخاصه
فقد تكون هناك شركات وقد يكون هناك تعاون
خصوصا عن الميدان الفلاحي بالاستفاده من
التجارب لانه اليوم اصبح
كثير من الكثير من الانماط الفلاحيه التي
كانت معتمده في بعض الدول وهذه المساله
اشرت اليها تقرير البنك الدولي منذ سنه
2015 مثلا زراعه الحبوب المرتبطه بالامطار
اصبح من غير المنصوح بها تتم في بعض الدول
مثلا بعض الاشجار لا يمكن ان تكون في
اماكن معينه
نظرا لارتباطها بشده او
يعني كثره اعتمادها على الماء يعني يجب
تجنب هذا النوع من الزراعات تمام تجنبها
وقد يكون هناك نوع من التكامل لانه بعض
الدول يمكنها ان تقوم بهذه الزراعات نظرا
مثلا لانتظام وجود المصادر المائيه فيها
يمكنها ان تتخصص مثلا في ذلك على ان تكون
هناك
زراعه اخرى مثلا كما يحدث في اسبانيا
اسبانيا لها منطقه مثلا الميريه هي منطقه
تكاد تكون صحراء فهي اعتمدت تقنيات سقي هي
نفسها الان التي تعتمد في المغرب ما يسمى
بالصقل التنقيط المرتبط ببرامج معلوماتيه
دقيقه جدا تؤدي الى الاستخدام الامثل لما
يوجد عندنا من الماء وابعاد على الاقل
الدعم عن الزراعات التي تستهلك الماء
بكثره وخصوصا تلك المواجهه للتصدير
فالتعاون الحكومي او التعاون بين الدول
هذا المستقبل او مستقبله في هذه المساله
اكثر من غيرها يعني مراجعه كامله للسياسه
الزراعيه للسياسه الزراعيه والسياسه
الفلاحيه لان بدون هذه المراجعه
سنسقط في هيمنه مثلا الشركات الكبرى التي
تلجا الى التصدير والتي لا تشغل بالها
بالماء ولا خلاف وانما المهم هو ايجاد نوع
معين من الفواكه من اجل التصدير وهذه
المساله اصبحت الان تطرح بحده فاصبح الان
الموضوع الاساسي هو مساله الدعم الحكومي
لبعض القطاعات الفلاحيه وما هي سياسه
الحكومه لاحتواء المشاكل التي تصيب العالم
الفلاحي وتؤثر كذلك سواء على التشغيل او
على المستوى المعيشي للساكنه في بعض
المناطق قال الاندلس مثلا وحتى في الوسط
في قشتاله وغيرها
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور زين العابدين الحسيني
على حضورك معنا هنا في الاستوديو شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من بغداد الدكتور نظير عبود
فزع ولضيفنا من باريس الدكتور بدوي رهبان
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]